okay let's get started I guess uh
everything is working now
Okay cool so
um last time we talked about the we
started to talk about the so-called
implicit regularization effect
of the optimizers
and
and last time we discussed the very
basic one which is that if you use on
initialization zero
and then
um is his greeting descent and you have
a regression problem a linear regression
problem
then what you get is that you get a
minimum Norm solution
this is the last time
and today we're going to talk about a
case where we have nonlinear models and
we'll see similar phenomena but we're
going to have a somewhat different proof
foreign
so
um
okay so I guess so let's uh
delve into the detail so this is the
non-linear model that we
um
you know you will see that this is now
this model is not linear but it's not
actually that much different from linear
model use as you will see
um
um there is a paper that can do a little
more than this but generally we don't
know how to do deal with you know very
complex models like deep Networks
so
um so this is the nonlinear model we're
going to consider
so suppose you have beta is the
parameter and X is the input and the
model is FX is equals to
the inner product between beta times o
dot beta and X so all doubt is the hard
mod
product meaning the anchovies product so
basically you
entry-wise Square the parameter
and then you take the inner product with
x
so this is still linear in X but it's
not linear in beta
um so so in terms of like I understood
the loss function
will be
non-convex
because it's not only the in beta and
you do the loss function you take your
Square then it becomes a non-convex so
it's not that interesting in terms of
you know the model itself because anyway
you are doing a linear model but from
the algorithm the implicit
regularization effect perspectively
still interesting because you have a
non-convex objective function
and we're going to make this even more
interesting by you know consider a
special case where suppose you have
ground shoes
um is that Y is equals to
beta star o dot beta star times x
where
beta star is R sparse
so the reason why we want beta star to
be R sparse is that
R sparse means that the zero Norm of
beta is less than r
like you only have
R non-zero entries
and the reason why we want to have this
restriction on beta star is because
uh we want to consider over
parenthesized models if you have over
parameters models meaning so we consider
the case where
n is
smaller than D when a is smaller than b
if beta is fully General beta star is
fully General then there is no way you
can hope to learn anything from from
less than dimensionality number of data
points so so basically I will make sure
beta star is sparse and so we assume
I'm going to assume that 10 is small
indeed but and it's larger than some
poly r
that's the setting where we are going to
work with
um
and more uh specific and for Simplicity
or without loss of generality let's
assume also beta star is larger than
zero entry-wise
because you can see that the sign of
videos that doesn't really matter in
terms of the functionality in terms of
the ground shoes model and actually for
Simplicity
of this lecture
of this lecture let's also assume that
beta is just some indicator on some
subside of course where
as is a subset of coordinates and the
size of s is equals to R
this is only for Simplicity of this
lecture
um
okay and now let's define the data so I
guess we have talked about that we are
going to have over parameterized our
model so we have undidable point and N
is less than D so this n data point are
denoted by X1 up to x n
let's say our ID from
gaussian
of Dimension work of spherical
covariance and y i is generated from
this model
without any error
so the Yi is just in a product beta star
times beta star
like is this inner product of square of
beta star times x i
so and
and is much much less than D but we
assume that
n is bigger than Omega
tilde of R square so n is roughly bigger
than R square
um and this so so this amount of data
points in principle that allows us to
recover beta stock actually you only
need
Omega R to recover beta star if you
can't dimensionality right so there are
degree of Freedom approximately so we
only need 10 to be lower than Omega R
but for the theory to work we have to
allow it to be larger than R square but
still you know if R is very small then
you still can like n much much smaller
than D and still bigger than r squared
let's say R is a constant that's
probably the right way to think about it
um any polynomial dependency on R is fun
and so that n is just something like a
big constant but n could be much less
than t
okay so and maybe so far after we Define
this you may wonder why we are why we
have to use this nonlinear model right
the answer is no you don't have to use
it if you really want to solve the
problem
so the nonlinear model is only
introduced to study this effect right
suppose you really care about solving
the question then you can use the
classical
um solution which is called La Sol so or
in the more
um
kind of like us you know terms using
terms with this we use in this lecture
you can use L1 regularization
so basically
basically
um so to Leverage sparsity
I think I'm not sure whether you all
have this background but typically
people use L1 to in some sense encourage
sparse vectors
um I'm not going to get into detail
there but
um you can show that you know if you
minimize the L1 Norm of theta of the of
the model then you can
um
um you can you can reconstruct spots
vectors so so in particular I think
suppose you have this model f Theta
uh X which is a linear X
then this is so called that's all this
is L1 regress objective which is
something like this
plus Lambda times L1 Norm of theta
so and and the the classical machine
learning theory I'm not going to go into
detail here in some sense this is you
know if you don't know the background
probably just the somewhat memorized it
or kind of like shaded it as a fact so
so the classical Theory
says that
if n is larger than r
say I think you need to pay a
logarithmic Factor here if a is larger
than R then this objective function
recovers the ground choice right
so objective
above
recovers
the ground shoes
Theta star
which is the
you can you can I guess you probably
already see the state of corresponds
beta up to this square square of the
thing so approximately
so basically if you just really care
about solving this question you view
this as a linear model you don't have to
care about the quadratic thing and then
use L1 regularization
to recover smart structure there's a
rich you know a lot of like existing
kind of cereal about this I'm not going
to the details but this is something you
know somewhat believable because
[Music]
um
um because you are using the sparsity of
the vector
um and also another thing to note is
that
because data and Theta the relationship
between beta and Theta is that
Theta corresponds to Beta o dot beta
Vector entryway Square
so and then
um that one Norm of theta
is equals to the two Norm square of beta
the one normal phase is the sum of
entries of theta which is equals the sum
of
right I squares which is a two Norm
square of beta
so so basically if you do the quadratic
one you can you should regularize L2
Norm right so so basically this
objective one corresponds to
um
L2 regularized objective
so
if you really want to use the quadratic
one you should do
the
the
quadratic parametricization you should
do this F beta X
I
square plus L Lambda 2 Norm beta squared
uh beta2 Norm square right this is the
objective
uh with respects beta
right so so in the beta space you should
regularize L2 down Square in the
cellular space you should request L1
right so
so this is the classical solution and
now we're talking about implicit
regularization
I think our goal is essentially
basically saying that if you
use small initialization
this is you know without regularization
without expressive regularization
this is kind of like basically doing the
same thing as let's call this two
so as long as you use small
initialization with beta parametrization
um you automatically get this L2 Norm
graduation for free to some extents this
is not exactly you know the the exact
way to freeze to State the theorem but
this is the rough basically the main
idea
so
um
so more concretely webinar we're
interested in is the objective High beta
let's formally Define it
I think I normalized by four here just
because it makes the gradient looks
cleaner
so uh but it's just constant Factor so
one over four and times the square loss
the mean
squared Arrow
right no regularization right so this is
our objective and we are going to do the
optimizer
will be that you do GD
and I operate height data
with
small initialization
and or more concretely so the algorithm
is for some
very small Alpha
larger than zero
we initialize beta
to be Alpha times all one vector
so you don't know the the support of
beta of course where you each initialize
all the answers by Alpha and then you
take a green descent update every time
so you say the beta key plus one is
equals to be the T minus
ETA times the gradient
ability
[Applause]
okay so this is the objective we are
going to study and we'll claim that this
objective oh sorry this is the optimizer
we're going to study we're going to
claim that this Optimizer actually
um
um actually finds the the beta stock
even though there is no explicit
representation
any questions so far
so so here is the theorem
so the theorem is that
basically you know the shorter version
of the theorem is that
is so a is Omega R square we can
converge to
this algorithm
converters to
to Beta star but let's let's but I think
there's a little bit kind of like a
uh with small Alpha
but there's a lot of detail so let me
State the main serum
so
I guess suppose
and is bigger than Big O of R square log
Square D
uh
so
Alpha
let me see
maybe let's writing is this way I think
just to avoid confusion so let's see if
your sufficient large constant
foreign
is bigger than c times R Square Times
log Square D I think the dependency on
the logarithmic factor is sub-optimal it
depends on the r probably is also
sub-optimal
um and
Alpha to be less than
some inverse poly into the C
then
when the time t t is the total number of
um the total number of
um steps is less than one over ETA
Times Square Root d alpha and bigger
than
log D over Alpha
over ETA so for this range of time steps
we have
you can recover beta o dot beta
foreign
with our Alpha Times Square D
[Applause]
okay so how do we interpret this
so
so I guess there are a few remarks for
interpretations
the first thing is that I guess this is
something probably I should have
mentioned earlier so I'll hype data
uh has many
Global mean
and why this is because
of over parametrization
because you know you have like if you
count a degree of Freedom you have
earned data points and D parameters
right so you have more degree of freedom
than the number of constants so you have
many many Global minimum
right so so that's that's one of the
reasons why you have implicit bias uh if
you want to have one Global minimum
there's no way you can have implicit
bias
um and
second thing how do we interpret all of
these quantities in the bond
so
so the run time
lower bound
depends
only on the logarithmic of alpha
so this means that you can choose Alpha
to be anything inverse polynomial
so Alpha can be
inverse poly
right you can choose basically the
constant C to be as to be a constant so
so then the runtime wouldn't be affected
too much
and an error
depends on Alpha
so basically if you want very very small
Arrow inverse poly error you can just
take Alpha to the inverse poly and your
run time is not changed too much
and there's the upper bound on the
runtime which means that
um
you need to do our early stopping
according to this Bond
so if you really believe in this you
have to do early starting but the early
stopping is pretty mild right but pretty
mild because you can see that the upper
bound actually depends on inverse Alpha
so if you take something like Alpha to
be one over D to the power 10 then your
upper bond is pretty relaxed you can run
for a long time right so I need an
action practice we never observe that
you have to if you really do the this
synthetic example really run experiments
you never have to already stop and I
probably I don't believe that you have
to already stop this is more or less
artifact of the
of the proof but this artifact is is is
not too restrictive anyways because
it depends on Alpha in the inverse of
the alpha so you can take Alpha to be
small to make the bond very relaxed so
so we didn't
um we didn't pay the attention to to to
remove that completely even though we
believe that's possible
um
anyway so basically the right way to use
this is that you take Alpha to be
something super small and and then your
error is very small and your run time is
your runtime lower bound is logarithmic
in awful
okay so there's one small thing is that
Alpha cannot be zero
so why you don't take Alpha to be zero
the only reason why Alpha cannot be zero
is because
zero beta is zero is a saddle point
so the number L height beta
is at zero it's zero
this is part will come from the
quadratic parametricization right so of
the group will complete the gradient you
will see that because you have the
quadratic parameters this is everything
the gradient always multiplied by Beta
itself so if beta is zero then you just
have zero gradient so so so so if the
grain is zero and if you don't if you
when we are analyzing wind designs no
noise nothing right so no one is the
plasticity so so if you start at zero it
will just stay there forever so that's
why you cannot
um you can use um zero
I think transition but anything close to
zero is five in some sense this log 1
over Alpha then you pay
how much time you have to pay to leave
the saddle port
so and the leaving Center Point is
actually very fast
that's in some sense you can kind of
believe it right because you have a
saddle point how do I draw it like
something like this
right so like leaving it is kind of like
you have it's it's optimizing a concave
function and you're going downhill right
you basically accelerates so fast that
eventually you leave it very quickly
so
Okay cool so
right and
and in some sense you can interpret this
as you know a gradient descent
is preferring prefers minimum Norm
solution
in L2
so so I may be preferring
sorry action
like a preferring Global minimum
um closest to
initialization
foreign
because we have kind of claimed that you
know so so actually here
I think we have
um
somewhat allude related to this but just
be formal in this case you can prove the
following
so you can prove that beta star is
actually the arc mean
of
the norm
with the Constitution that
you fed the data
suppose you try to find a global minimum
with the minimum L2 Norm
right so
this is the constraint right so this
means you have a global minimum if you
satisfies everything
um and you minimize the two Norm then
this is actually equals to Beta star
and and the reason why this is true is
kind of like similar to why the i1 norm
works right just because
the minimum the two Norm of beta is the
same as the one Norm of theta
and and this one
if you replace this base Theta then this
is true
and and this part
is by
the
uh the standard Theory
which I didn't show but you know that if
you look at all the linear models that
face the data you look as far as this
one it's going to be the
um
the Theta actually technically I think
this should be argument to the o.2
because sorry
to the square root because there's a
there's a translation
like the objective is the same but the
but the arc means has the translation
I'm not sure whether that makes
that's right so like so if you so maybe
I slice it
maybe the easiest way to write this is
the following so
so these two are exactly the same
just because you have a translation if
you look at me
right and for the first object if the
argument is beta star and then you can
somehow see that the arc mean also
transfers you know just by taking a
square root
so and this is also the case for linear
regression right recall that we also
proved that if you start with green
designs with zero and you do linear
regression you get the minimum solution
that face the data so it's very similar
at least from the on the surface from
the formulas
like uh like you have you have almost
the same guarantee
but but I don't necessarily believe that
this is always the case for all the kids
like I don't feel like you you always
find the minimum Norm social the
solution that is closest to
initialization
let's face the data I don't think this
is always true it's probably
I think there's still some something
special about this examples
yeah we cannot just extrapolate them
generically
Okay so
now
uh we are going to try to prove this any
questions so far
foreign
I'll try to finish it in one lecture but
if we cannot I think I'm going to refer
you to the notes the notes has a pretty
detailed derivation
so
um so so to to kind of get some
preparation let's try to understand
uh some basic stuff about this loss
function
so
so first of all let's look at the
population risk
this is the population no hat
if the population risk is
y minus
Bit O DOT beta times x
squared
right so and you can try to
um
get rid of the expectation because uh
this is population so what you do is you
plug in a definition of y so you get
beta star o dot beta star minus
beta0. beta times x
squared
and then this gives you
I think I have one force here that's my
population right because
um I know I have the additional four
everywhere
so and this becomes one force
times the norm
the difference in Norm
this is just because
the expectation of
some Vector times x square if x is
gaussian this is equals to
the norm of B to know
Square One
so and
uh
and I'm going to click the following so
you're going to have uniform convergence
for sparse beta
so but we don't have uniform convergence
over the entire space right because we
have over parenthesization that's the if
you have overpowerment uniform
convergence for everything then
they wouldn't have any implicit
regularization effect
so that would be the kind of the
classical
uh theory that we discussed in the first
part of the
uh the first part of the um
the the course right so but but we claim
that if you look at sparse beta then you
have uniform converges
so so here is the um I'm going to build
I'm going to build towards this so first
there's a claim
which is with high probability
um over the choice of data
so for if n is bigger than something
like
this oh tilde of R over Delta Square
then for every V
such that
foreign
then you have the following so
the empirical average of this kind of
things right so why we care about this I
guess this is probably going to be seen
here right so this is the pop the
population has this form something like
V Dot x square and you take a stackation
and this is the Imperial one I'm going
to be more explicit in a moment but this
time is it's kind of like
a small tool so you're saying that if
you have this empirical version of this
V Dot x square
and it's going to be very close to the
population version the population is
just the two Norm of V squared right
um so it's going to be very close to
the
population
but only for V that is sparse
so this concentration only works so so
if you have enough ends right if n is
infinite then or close to infinite then
you should expect this to work for every
V just because this is a lot of law of
large number or like a concentration in
the qualities right but here the
Constitutional code is more subtle or
more
kind of like there's a funny Finance
here because you only care about
um these that are sparse and also you
only have this many of examples you
don't have
a lot of examples and it's not on bigger
than D even right and it's only bigger
than the sparsity of beef
so
so this is uh and actually this is also
called
so and also just the follow from the
language I guess this is something
useful to to know you know we don't
really have any depend on this kind of
purpose but we we say that
uh if if a vector satisfied this
condition
suppose let's call this three
so suppose
X I's
satisfy
3 then we call
then then we say
this satisfied rip condition so
basically three is called R Delta
rip condition
the acronym is a little bit kind of
weird but I think there is
standing for restricted
ISO
magic condition
the reason why it's called restricted is
because you are only restricting to
vectors V
but if you are not restricting to vector
v then this is a kind of like isometric
condition because you are basically
seeing that all the X i's are ISO
isometric right they are they are kind
of spreading the entire all the
directions equally right the exercise
has Converse identity that's pretty much
what do I say right so if you don't if
you require this for every V then you
are saying that the the covariance of so
you know what this is really saying this
equation three is really just equivalent
to
sum of x i
transpose times V transpose times V
is uh
right this is like bounded by V
transpose I times V times 1
Delta larger than one minus Delta times
B transpose I times B right so if you
require this for every B so suppose
require
D for every V
then what this is saying is
sum of x i
transpose small n is
in PSD sense
how do I write this poster
okay how do I write MPS
wait
oh okay right
background notation for PS yeah like
this
less than one plus Delta times lnt and
larger than 1 minus Delta template so if
you call it for every V you are
basically seeing the covariance of x i
are as ASO as some
I think it's called not called isometric
it's called
I so it's a magic ISO parametrics it's
just covalented six Source or anything
right that's I'm blocking on the word so
so basically you're seeing the
covariance is closer but you are not
requiring for every V right and also
this is not true for if you don't have
enough data right so we only have n is
less than data point so so in our case
this Matrix is not even full rank how
come you can expect the food this is
this only has rank r because it only has
a record n because we only have undated
points and is less than this so it's not
even a full graph Matrix how come this
can be close to an entity there's no way
right but if you look at the quadratic
form right so if you look at a quadratic
form
and you only look at the quadrilage form
evaluated on sparse vector v then this
Matrix becomes
effectively look like an entity
that's basically what this condition is
saying
right okay so
um and once you have this um Lemma or
this claim then uh we know that you have
the uniform convergence
for beta
sparse so sparse beta
and this is just because you know
uh I always had beta
is this one
times 4 times 1 over n times sum of
beta oh dot beta minus beta star oh dot
beta star times x i squared
and this is of this form right so you
can treat this as V
and then your urine is Formula V Dot x i
Square
right and this V is sparse if beta is
sparse and beta stars as far as beta
star is always sparse that's our
assumption and if beta is foreign this
thing is also sparse you you pay 2 hours
password there were R stars and
and now
um this whole thing would be probably
two hours
at most so then this means that this is
close to
um the norm right so one times four
times the norm of this
and and this is equals to L beta
so so for sparse beta you have uniform
convergence but you don't have uniform
convergence over the entire space
so in some sense on uh
so and also you can have
uniform convergence
for the gradient
of this if you really care about it
um I guess
I think I will show this later uh
for
for sparse
wait so you can even show the gradient
concentrate
um around the expected gradient the
empirical gradient
concentrate around
the population gradient
for smart speed
so however on the other hand
there exists
dance beta
such that
for example L height beta is zero
but L beta is very much lower than zero
so they are they are over 15 positions
there's there are places where you don't
have the
the property the training and test laws
are similar so but those are dense beta
okay so the question is why you're
offending a sports one but not a dance
one right because the dance one doesn't
have the nice property so the main
intuition is the following so we have
done quite some preparation so many
intuition
or or what we believe to be happening is
that following so you can think of this
every different XR
to be uh
to be the spider vectors that are sparse
so beta such that
with our spores
let's see what they are used to
so and
so suppose you look at the space right
so you have an entire space which is
probably something very large
and zero is somewhere here this is the
origin
and you have a
some family of let's call this XR this
is the family of sparse vectors
and
and you know in this XR everything
behaves so nicely the tuning and tests
are just basically the same up to
like like a up to some small error right
so the training test and also in terms
of gradients they are similar the green
of L hat and green of L are similar and
and I think basically what happens is
that you start from somewhere close to
zero and the reason you cannot start at
zero just because the setup ones not
very important and you can think of like
a green descent so you are doing good in
this sense
uh
on the empirical loss L hat beta
uniform convergence is
you're basically doing the same thing as
screening designs on our beta
as long as you don't leave this type XR
right so if you leave it there's all
better off but if you don't leave it
it's fine
right so it turns out that
what happens is that if you do when you
design you can consider the alternative
world where you do green descent on a
population
so let's say this is the green descent
on a population loss L beta
and if it turns out if the green is in a
population you are going to reach a
point
which is beta star which is kind of on
the boundary of this side
um and because and also in this
transaction you never leave this set XR
right so now because you believe that
the
the black trajectory is similar to the
purple trajectory
as long as they are in the set XR and
the purple trajectory is never leave
this set XR so you be so that's why the
black trajectory also converts to Beta
star
I'm not sure whether that makes sense so
so basically the purple one is the
population trajectory and black one is
the empirical structures
so you know that the empirical
introduction and the population
structure are similar in the set XR you
don't know anything about outside the
world right so and also you know the
proper structure never leaves the set XR
then the black one probably shouldn't
leave as well and the black one should
be similar to the purple one right so so
for example it's the pose suppose the
purple structure look like this
suppose that's the what's happening then
you lose control because at the
beginning you you're following the
proper structure and then you leave this
side and then all that's off you don't
have any control anymore but this turns
out to be not what's happening what's
happening is that the purple after stays
in the set XR like for a long time like
you know until it reaches beta star
and then stay a bit of star so that's
that's why this alternative
situation doesn't happen
right this doesn't happen
this is not what's happening and
inside this XR everything behaves nicely
there's only a global minimum which is
beta star there's nothing else and also
at XR there are a bunch of different
things right so outside Sr you can
imagine that there is a
it's a different color so all set XR
there's probably
acquired a bunch of overfitting
Solutions
so these are all solutions that makes
the
the the report Clause zero there are so
many of these Solutions
but you never get to actually even go to
those places just because your your
black trajectory
is emitting the purple one and the
purple one didn't go to those places and
the black one doesn't go to those places
either
right so so that's the that's the
intuition uh why this is working
any questions
but why the purple one doesn't leave
though yeah so that's not uh I don't
have I didn't give a justification
either right that's um that's something
we're gonna prove yeah um
um and I don't think this this is
something about the property of this
problem
um and
um if you see the proof it's not that
surprising because you are gradually you
are in some sense with instance trying
to you know it's a local search
algorithm right so you are trying to
search your neighborhood first right so
your gradually kind of like a
um you start from zero somewhere close
to zero you're gradually searching on
neighborhood until you find the global
mineral that's why you don't want to
probably wouldn't go this circuitous way
uh right so like so you're gonna go more
straight to the to the to the closest
point
um but but the real proof has to go
through the math
yeah that's a great question so so the
initialization Alpha times one
right so this is literally speaking is
not in XR right it's it's that
um and I got to ask this question many
times and I think the right way to think
about this
I think I had some remarks somewhere
else but you asked it early I should
probably should just really answer it
here so the so the question is why the
initialization is not in XR but I think
the thing to think about is that
um of course it's not exactly in this
far set but it's close and closing was
done closing the sunset
Alpha One is very close to
zero and zeros is in this set
so so that's that's the kind of like the
the the profit we're going to use so so
yes so you are right that you know we
never we can never say exactly you know
you're you're gonna say that you're in
the neighborhood of XR with a little bit
smaller and the arrow is very small it
depends on Alpha so uh and if that's why
we have to choose Alpha to be very small
so in some sense you really want to
choose zero so so like from the all of
this discussion the only the only thing
you want to do is to choose zero and and
but zero it just happens to be a set of
one that's unfortunate so you have to
perturbate a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
so the question is whether this this
particular property has anything to do
with the positivity
of beta right so
um
I don't think so
um because so are you talking about the
positive way to start or by data the
variable data
okay let's start right so so we assume
the data start to be positive
um
I think no matter where the star of beta
is positive
is positive
beta star square is always positive
right so
so so you can if you initialize from
this then you just always go to the Post
it's always keep being positive so
basically you just learn the absolute
value of beta stock
and if you're learning the absolute
value of beta star is not that different
from
learning better stock so so basically
suppose you don't receive Capital start
to be positive then you cannot claim
that you recover beta star you can only
say you cover the absolute value of beta
star
yeah but but the picture the the
intuition is still the same after that
changes
yeah so the question
yes so I guess the question is whether
we really have to be exactly Alpha times
or one vector right so and the answer is
this is a great question the answer is
no you don't have to do that the only
thing you have to do is that you
initialization beta0 this is a vector I
think you only need to make sure every
entry of it
is very small so you only need to make
sure this infinite Norm is very small
less than something like Alpha
um and
yeah and and then you can even UniFirst
negatively I think so if you need for a
snake fluid and then the action will
become negative eventually
but the sun doesn't matter that much so
that's fine
yeah but yeah so so so so so so and I'm
only doing this just for convenience
because it makes the proof cleaner right
Okay so
so given this uh plan this intuition so
it's natural that we should start
analyzing the population traction right
like the purple one right so and then we
try to say that the black one is close
to purple so so so let's start with the
population trajectory
right so you can sometimes think of this
as a warm up or in some sense this is a
also a kind of similarly check for for
this approach right so
so this is I'm let me let me say the
theorem formally but I think you are
expected with a Serum is saying right GD
on the population loss Will converge to
beta star and and
in
I think all log
one over Epsilon Alpha over ETO
tuition
with
Epsilon error
in L2 distance
okay
so but I guess the formal theorem
matters less than the the proof
um let's see how the proof goes the
proof is kind of Brute Force
um because you just really literally
control
each what each of the coordinates is
doing
so so it's pretty expensive and you see
how the coordinates are changing
um but the expression is actually a
weakness in some sense because because
you are doing so explicit derivation
it's great for this problem
but it's very it's harder to be
extendable
I think that's the that's a general
thing right so if you have a very
various kind of strong analysis for toy
case that no that's not necessarily
always the good case because if it's too
strong too explicit then the
expandability the the applicability to
broader case becomes a problem
um and and this is in my opinion the
probably the the main reason why we
cannot extend to more General cases
other than this simple quadratic one
there's there's a small cut there's a
there's extension to the matrices case
but not fundamental extension so you can
change all of these to matrices instant
vectors that's still fun but not beyond
that okay so but still anyway let me do
the an analysis so
the proof sketch is that you first
complete the gradient we call that L
beta
so L beta is equals to 1 4 times beta0.
beta minus beta star
I'm gonna open the star two Norm square
and you can compute a gradient with
respect to Beta it becomes beta o dot
beta minus beta star or dot Bill store
times
odog beta I guess you can kind of verify
this you know with
um pretty much you know scalars but the
vector version is pretty much
taking the sum of the scalar all the
dimensions right so here all the
dimensions are
separated
so so we basically this is the sum of
the objective and each objective is
about one coordinate and it's just a
simple chain Rule and you can see that
everything is multiplied by Beta always
right the Boolean is always multiplied
with beta and this is why when L 0 is 0.
so and now let's look at uh the update
the update will be beta t plus 1 is
equals to Beta T minus ETA times it's
beta t o dot
let's play the Star o dot beta star
timeso dot beta t
okay so so and this is this is really
this is everything is in B Dimension but
really you can view this as D separate
update
in in the coordinates
because each coordinates are not doing
having any kind of correlation with
anything else
so so this is really just the saying
that bti is equals to bti minus ETA
bti Square
minus B
star I a square
times
bti
okay so so every corner are just doing
separate things
and
um and maybe maybe it's used and but
this different course has a lot of
differences
right because this one is different
otherwise all the chords are doing the
same thing so the target is different
so in some sense you're basically so
when
uh when I is in the support
of beta star
which is denoted to be as
so then your update is basically beta I
is updates V beta I minus ETA
with I Square minus 1
with I
and when I guess a moment in the T just
for for notational Simplicity and if I
is not in the support of beta
star
um then beta I is just up a to B with
the I minus ETA
with i squared Cube
so and you can see this includes all of
this intuitive makes sense because
suppose this is the case then
if so beta is suppose is less than one
between zero right that's suppose that's
the current rate of I and this number is
negative
this is positive so this whole thing is
an active so you are trying to increase
beta
right so so basically so this update is
trying to increase by the eye if beta is
not not yet reaching one
and this update is doing the reverse
direction right so this is trying to say
that as long as your beta I is bigger
than zero then you are trying to
decrease your beta I
so so basically here this encourages
beta I to go to one and this encourage
the speed I to go to zero
and that makes sense because Y is the
beta I star and zero is the beta I star
in in the other case
right so
um
okay so and now let's try to do a more
uh detailed calculation to see what what
happens in each of these case so let's
first look at the case one let's say
this case one and this case two
case one
so so here we are trying to you know the
update is trying to increase beta I
until it reaches one right so there are
still two separate cases the first case
is that suppose beta I is less than at
some time T is less than half
so you're only half done your work and
then you can see what's the changes so
bet iot plus one is equals to
beta I T minus ETA
beta i t squared minus 1
with i t
and
we argue that this is trying to increase
with I and we can see how much it
increases beta I it increases beta I by
this Factor ETA times 1 minus
with it
square right so you have a
multiplicative Factor
so in some sense you're multiplying a
beta I to make it bigger but how much
you can you make it bigger you know it
depends on
the value of beta itself but if we know
that beta is not too big then we can
bound this by
beta i t times 1 plus ETA
one minus a quarter
which is a
bigger than beta is equal to
by the IIT one plus three four times e
times
so so we have exponential growth
and
[Music]
if
beta I is already bigger than half
right then let's see what happens
so now the growth rate might be slower
slow down because if you see if beta is
kind of close to one then it's this
this much this this constant is becomes
close to zero so your growth rate slows
down
um and that's true but what you can do
is you can analyze how
far you are away from
one from your target
and if you look at how far you're away
from one then you get the following
recursion
uh minus ETA times 1 minus beta i t
square with i t
and
so and let's try to reorganize this a
little bit
so
I guess let's say
I think let's assume this let's assume
this is
also likes the one
and then this is less than
sorry let me think
foreign
have to assume this let's
remove this for the moment this is less
than one minus beta I T minus ETA
T Square Times a half
right because beta i t is bigger than
half
and now you can factorize this to get a
factor one minus beta i t out
and this one minus ETA 1 plus beta i t
times a half
all right and
I guess it might be a little bit kind of
like you might get you may feel like
this is a little bit unnatural but I
think if you if you see my final Target
I guess you know it's probably actually
not super difficult to to guess how to
do the intermediate steps so now I'm
going to use the fact that paid IIT is
bigger than zero
so get one minus beta ID
1 minus beta times a half
so so my point is that if you look at
the final outcome you see that
now you are not growing exponentially
but you are converging to one
exponentially fast so you are decreasing
your error
you are required decreasing your
distance to one in your exponentially
fast
all right
so in some sense this this behavior of
these Dynamics has two regime right so
when you are small you are growing very
very fast and then when it becomes
bigger then your growth rate slows down
but you are converting to one
exponentially cost
so so that's why if you combine these
two regime then you are you and also you
can see that
you can also see that this maintains
beta I is less than one right so because
if you before you are less than one and
later you're gonna be also less than one
so so so basically the behavior is that
if you summarize so basically in
log 1 over
Alpha over ETA iteration
you are in the first you are in the
first regime so
so you so this is beta i t
grows
to a half exponentially fast
exponentially right and you only need to
use this number of iterations because
you you initially it's Alpha and you
want to grow to a half so you I guess
technically you also have a two here if
you want
um
right so and you have a learning ETA so
so basically this is because one over
eater the half to the power
suppose this T1 T1 this is something
like
at least
sorry this is
guys this is your growth the factor that
you growth and you you take you find
some power to it and then you want to
grow at least a half over Alpha factor
and and that's how you solve this number
T1 okay but anyway so
um so so this is how okay the first part
and then
in
log one over Epsilon over ETA iteration
beta i t
convert this to
one minus Epsilon
and this is because you want to start
from a half the hour half to Arrow
absolute and each time you decrease by
one minus E to over two so that's why
you have to pay
this number of iterations
because this makes sense
I guess this is there is a small thing
that I probably escaped in some sense
right so this is about how do you kind
of derive how many iterations you need
right so if you want one plus beta to
the power T to be bigger than
some number R then this means T needs to
be bigger than
log r
over over ETA
so this is just something that bursting
burning into my hack but you you can you
can develop it yourself as well
Okay cool so
all right so so that's what happens with
those coordinates that you want to
convert to one
and you also have case two
and you can do the same thing I don't
necessarily want to bore you with all
the derivations but I guess the
derivations here is easy
because you're just trying to say beta I
is
decreasing right in the speed right so
and
and here
let's see
and here interestingly
so
um
so if you really look at literally look
at this
uh
this is actually saying that you are
decreasing beta I eventually to zero but
somehow we care about something weaker
that is more
uh
let me see
I'm acting a plus here so I don't know
why I'm
I think I'm not missing a plus
[Applause]
which is let me make sure I don't make
any mistake here
foreign
Okay so
I think
I think what I do here like uh I have
some derivation here some small claim
here which is particularly useful for
uh the the empirical case
um which I'm not sure I can get into so
I'm gonna skip this part so so at least
for now it's sort of trivial to see that
beta I is decreasing
right if you start with Alpha and then
you keep being smaller than Alpha that's
that sounds trivial to see and and maybe
let's just uh leave it there
um this is enough for for us to deal
with the population case
right so so basically our conclusion is
you can see that the conclusion is that
you converge
to something close to one
uh in this number of iterations right
the filtration count is something
logarithmic times one over ETA
and you also have this property that you
you are always less than one right all
the answers are less than one
and also
the the the the the small entries are
never growing
so basically your beta
T at any time
basically looks like there are a bunch
of entries which is growing right so the
S and also in the in the ice complement
in the ice complement all of these
entries is less than Alpha
Fiverr and in this cup in the in the ice
coordinates you are growing potentially
so so you can see that this is still
always approximately our Sparks because
at least you only have our big non-zero
entries and all the other entries are
very small
so approximately this is still always
approximately in the XR
just because the small entries are keep
being small
okay so now let's try to talk about the
empirical case a little bit
um
I think this full analysis it probably
wouldn't would fit within 15 minutes but
I think I can give you some idea about
it
and actually I'm going to only do the
placement R is one because R is more
than one it's kind of like a little bit
complicated
um so I'm going to do the the
R is one case
so
all right
so got that
so for some Delta and when R is one
and it's less than Omega of one so
basically you only have to have
logarithmen of examples
and then GD
competitor had
this is just a simplification of the
theorem we have already stated I guess
uh now the
I guess this is also actually weaker
maybe I should say
it's a weaker serum
not only weaker in the sense of
simplification but also weaker so weaker
and simplified
um so you get this iteration
steps
we have
it's less than o to the power square
root
so here I guess this is the why this is
weaker than what we have said before
before the arrow can goes to zero as
long as you take Alpha to be small
enough
right so
so this is weaker
because error
doesn't go to zero
so before we can make the error goes to
zero as Alpha goes to zero and now you
want to prove that it depends on
something like the number of examples
um this is just a technicality like if
you want to prove the case when the
error goes to zero you have to do actual
work
um which is probably too much for this
course
um
right so
how do I do this so in some sense
um the proof is trying to
in some sense maybe let me the proof
idea
and sometimes it's pretty intuitive like
like given that the this figure we have
joined John
um so you are just trying to show that L
hat beta is close to L beta and that's
something you can prove very easily so
you try to prove that
so one you try to prove that lhydrator
is close to L beta
for every beta that is
I guess technically you have to say this
is approximately sparse
because you can never be exactly as far
as we discussed
so that's something that is relatively
easy
and all and the second thing is that you
want to say that the beta G
uh under for the for the empirical case
thank you
empirical trajectory
in the empirical trajectory
never leaves
uh this XR
very far right
but never never leave it uh
significantly
so so so how do we show two basically
you are trying to say that you are
staying close to the so you basically
want to Arrow to not
uh to note
uh blow up so what does that mean so it
means that maybe let's draw something
here so so you're trying to show two
trajectories that are close to each
other just forever right so so you have
a trajectory which is the purple one
this is the green distance
and what happens is after you take the
first step you you have some error here
right so now these two tractors are not
doing the same thing anymore right
initially you are taking the Grid in
that same plot and now this purple one
is taking green at this point
and and the black ones think moving at
this point
so you have this error in in not in
terms of the the griding not different
but also in terms of the the difference
at of the points where you are
evaluating your gradients so it's
empirical versus population that's one
difference and the other thing is that
you are evaluating the empirical and
population growth at different places
and that could introduce a bigger error
and then it will be introduced even
bigger error so so if you don't do this
carefully then it's possible that
eventually you go this way and the other
one goes the other way that's because
the error keep blowing keep being bigger
and bigger so basically you have to kind
of control
uh how the error control how the error
changes
so that's the that's the key part
and and this boils down to a lot of
different a lot of kind of like
at least on the surface similarly very
boring calculations uh if you really
want to do all this calculation well you
have to understand a little bit about
you know what each term means
um and it does require some extra work
um
um but but but for the first level thing
is that you know at least the
um
this whole thing is a simplification of
one of the paper I wrote
um a few years back and and when we did
this thing like the first thing we tried
is that we just tried to do the
calculation so like and you try to
understand which term is problematic
which term may cause a bigger blow up
and and then you focus more on that term
and attention and then try to understand
a little bit of random and then maybe
some if I divide some inequalities but
basically below this below is this level
like it becomes like a quite technical
so um
so I think I'm going to probably spend
another five minutes to do a little bit
just like a uh things so so I think the
the thing for you to kind of control
this error is that one thing we realized
is useful is that actually this is
actually important
kind of like conceptual you know
semi-conceptual kind of like uh thing
that we realized right so to control
this how this error is good to represent
your
uh each of it in your in a convenient
way
so so what does that mean so it means
that the beta star will assume better
start we assume R is one already right
so let's assume beta star
is just E1 right so it's just a one zero
zero zero
right so you just want to say that you
Converse to this this vector
and
one of the useful thing we did is that
we take beta T to be we write beta T to
be RT times E1 plus arrow Vector Zeta t
so especially you write it to is
a multiplication of beta star and some
error
so so in some sense like beta star is
here and you're starting from zero and
you try to
say how much you are different from this
this line so this is our data T this is
your RT times E1 that's how you
represent where you're at at time t
and and you want to keep and what we did
is that we want to say the RT
the plan is that you want to say RT is
going to 1
because eventually you want to go to E1
and Zeta T the error term
is keep is always small
small
I think we prove it to be smaller than
of alpha
for energy
that's how that's the the next level
right so and
and then you basically what you have to
do you have to try to derive derive
a recursion
for RT
and 0 t
right and we'll derive the recursion for
both of these two things right you can
always keep in mind that what happens
with the population
right so so so so so so so the recursive
for art and you can have the same
recursion for the population case
so so basically you're gonna have um so
suppose let's folks for example talk
about
let me see which one I can talk about
easily
uh let's see
simplify those notes I think I had some
backup plan yes here so
so
basically for example if you look at the
recursion for RT it looks like RT plus
one RT is equals to RT minus beta
RT squared minus 1 times RT
minus some term
that depends on Zeta t
so if you do like I have all of these
formulas written here but I don't want
to show all the details so and if you
look at this this is very similar
to the the thing that we had before
I guess I don't know why I'm let me also
change the the superscript
I think I should probably have
yeah in my nose is also super script
okay I guess you know I guess let me now
change everything just you know you know
like superscript is the same as the here
so if you look at this one this part
this is the same as update for the beta
we had
right so
where is the update for data
here right
so this is the case when when you are
looking at the coordinate where you have
a
entry one in the beta star so and this
is the update right so and if you just
replace beta I to the RT you get the
same formula right so RT has the same
formula
so so this so basically this part is
where the population grid does
and and you already analyze this part
already
so
um so so basically the only thing you
have to deal with is that how does the
error term uh affect you and and you
inductively show the error is small so
under the assumption that error is small
then you can show that the update for RT
uh is is basically doing the same thing
as the updates for the beta key before
so so that's how you deal with rt but
how do you know the data T is small that
becomes even more complicated because
data T also has a derivative recursion
right so zlt has a person which is I
think I don't even see a simple way to
write it I can actually have something
like this so Zeta T is equals to
30 minus
something like
some Matrix Mt times Theta t
some Vector sorry
come back to Low T times Little T
something like this
I'm not going to Define goatee and and
what you do is that this
is
somewhat similar
to the case to
those I not in eyes
the beta I the T recursion
so you know it's not so okay what's the
beta ID recursion the beta it recursion
was something like beta i t plus 1 is
equals to Beta i t
so let's eat up with I
T cubed so I think this if you really
look at the derivation I think this is
something like
beta i t Square minus 0 times beta i t
so if you really
to the the
match the terms I think these two
matches and these two matches and
something here which also matches if you
look at the details to some extent not
exactly
but but but but you somehow kind of have
a you know there's there's no way to
match everything exactly but you just
use this as use the beta of it as a
reference for you and you know that
something already matches and what does
match is this this roachy which I didn't
Define to this beta T square and you do
some kind of like concentration to show
that they are similar
and and what exact conversation you show
it's also actually up to the exact terms
and and somehow you you sometimes you
relate the data to recursion to the beta
recursion
um under the hood so that you can show
that that it doesn't grow on uh
eventually right because you knew beta T
doesn't grow right that's what we proved
easily and and once you can relate
delity to better tea then you can also
try to show that he doesn't grow uh
eventually
um
I think that's the
pretty much the the best thing I can do
in a short amount of time
um and and the details are in the notes
um
any questions
sorry yes I think I it was RT plus one
that when I changed the superscript to
subscript I forgot yeah yeah thanks
foreign
last lecture we saw two examples where
reading designs convert this to
a solution that is closest to the
initialization and but why empirical you
still have to use the express
memorization that we decay
so
um
I think I would like to argue that um
empirically the way Decay is actually
not very
uh not very strong
so so so there so it's not even clear
whether the way the case is really doing
over organizations
because
um
with the same radical actually can
memorize the chain of data like you can
you can even memorize oh sorry you can
even memorize string data with random
labels
so so um so suppose you permit your
label
there's no packing it's just random
label you can still use the same way
Decay uh and and train your network with
the same way decade to find a zero hour
solution so that seems to us that the
way the case not really doing that much
of a regularization in fact at least not
as strong as
the theoretical setting would say well
for example in this case suppose or in
this case of the previous case where
suppose use may depend you usually find
the minimum solution
then
um use a strong like a regularizer to
say you want to find a solution with
small Norm then you cannot fit random
labels anymore
so
um and also another kind of like tricky
thing is that the way decay in practice
also has some other effects that kind of
like kind of regulate for example how
the best generalization is working
and like if for example I think like if
you have specialization
then
the model becomes scale environment
so so like it becomes like a
like uh like how like if you multiply
all the ways by two technically you
don't you don't change anything
but somehow you want to recognize that
you want to kind of like regulate that
in some way because in certain cases it
changes to
um the optimization so so basically okay
I guess I don't have a very concrete
this is a good question I don't have a
very concrete answer but I think the the
thing we believe is that the way Decay
is not actually doing a strong work in
terms of the standard normalization of
the norm like regularization of the norm
and also we somehow suspected the way it
has some other effects to some extent
and also sometimes the way Decay is not
even important right so if you remove
the weight because
um you still got pretty good results in
certain cases so
um I guess that's the the best we know
for now yeah
any other questions
okay sounds good I guess I'll see you on
Wednesday